let's let's talk about the gays so okay
so marriage in Oklahoma gay marriage
it's going to happen because a judge
overruled the gay marriage ban pretty
good okay we all agree i think that
that's pretty good but then Republican
Mike Turner is proposing that they throw
out marriage altogether in Oklahoma as a
way of getting around gay marriage he's
so clever isn't he critics are calling
it a political stunt supporters say it's
what Oklahomans want they're willing to
have that discussion about whether or
not marriage needs to be regulated by
the state at all representative mike
turner says his fellow conservative
lawmakers feel the same way finding a
way around the court's decision to
strike down Oklahoma's ban on same-sex
marriage by not providing marriage at
all would it be realistic for the state
of Oklahoma to say we're not gonna do
marriage period that would definitely be
a realistic opportunity and that's
something that would be part of the
discussion that man is a [ __ ] idiot
he the sanctity of marriage that's what
they're always talking about he's
willing to throw out marriage altogether
in his state just so the gays can't get
married uh is this nothing more than a
political stunt or am i a cynic I'm
gonna have to know I kind of agree with
him I think that if with the right wing
is gonna get its panties in a knot about
the word marriage yeah and calling
same-sex unions marriage then fine get
take the government out of the marriage
business entirely have everybody get the
same level of benefits from their civil
union or whatever you want to call it
and leave marriage to the church there
are some churches that will marry
same-sex couples there are some churches
that won't but you know what when I got
my first communion I didn't go to the
DMV to get applied for so make marriage
a religious thing and make with a
societal government thing something else
that everybody gets equal access to
right okay so there's there's obviously
a solid argument in that and that
there's a difference between the
religious and of it and the civil long
as Oklahoma lets same-sex couples and
and opposite-sex couples get the same
stuff right I'm fine with it were okay
so i can i can go along with you on that
but this is still just a political this
guy doesn't really want a baby
I'm gonna give you that innocent and
it's is so focused something crybaby is
realize how crazy he make it look and
let's keep it real this guy if he's
married I think is uh is pro-life so
sick of this woman said well Isis what
kisses in this what I actually the
divorce they could call this bill taking
our ball and going home I mean that's
that is what's happening here but on one
level I am I'm down with that I think
that if if the it the institution of
marriage as though it were this
unchanged thing over the millennia which
it isn't because you know with women
don't come with dowries anymore um you
know I think if if if if it that's the
thing that is standing in the way of of
same-sex couples and and and same-sex
parents being treated differently in
this country then ditch it right but not
really though because it is happening
one it not really but I'm just saying I
i I'm I'm all as long as we're equal as
long as we get the same goods as
everybody else call it whatever but I'm
but don't call yours a marriage and call
mine a union yeah we're all unions are
all marriages is this one of these
issues that this guy in particular my
car is this one of these things where
it's like in a way our countries too big
because most people the polls show it
have moved past the gay marriage thing
gay people are sick about talking you
know nobody wants to talk about anymore
we get it and people just want to call
but with then we have these people in
these tiny little districts that say
crazy things and then it makes national
news so is it is a partly a problem of
just how our whole system operates but
is he is this gonna take him anyways
what I wonder right is a winning issue
what any in his little district in
Oklahoma to get to what love i mean it
this this is a national politics
obviously but then if there's a big
political studies gets but he's getting
some attention for it now you can move
forward to what is this guy's a haircut
deadly there comes a new Supreme Court
that's okay told ya desperately no the
Supreme Court just needs to finally once
and for all lay it down and let us move
past this because frankly if it weren't
for loving versus Virginia if you still
let it up with the state's decide
Mississippi would not have interracial
marriage the most recent surveys out of
that state shows a majority people are
still against it but tough toenails
majority of Mississippi these are human
rights you don't get to vote on human
right
and so if the until the Supreme Court
finally lays down a similar hammer about
same-sex marriage we have to deal with
every little piddly county state you
know thing about this issue so is this
really the fall to the Supreme Court
exam I'm glad you brought that up
because even when they flip prop 8 they
said it was just for california and the
standing issue wasn't even about the
merits of the the case so is there any
reason to believe that they well for so
we don't know that's going back there
again anytime I think eventually a case
is going to be the one that they're
gonna have to make up their mind on and
when they do that I think then we're
gonna we're gonna move past as people
are gonna be rankled about it but were
it's not gonna be an issue in court
that's why you keep here in terms like
states rights and in an hour we have to
keep but let these states each decide on
what they want to do and I in religious
freedom all these things these small
things to keep it in sir to people like
in Mississippi who still don't believe
in even interracial marriage yeah so uh
this guy Mike cuz i was about call mike
rogers that's the guy who out closet do
politicians mike turner uh is he also
just an example of why we can't have
good politicians anymore that that our
system is so screwed up you know i mean
everybody secrets and now you know
everyone's knit nude pictures are gonna
be out there and that we're now going to
grow up an even further generation of
people you're never gonna get good
people to go into politics anymore
because this because of the scandals and
the news cycle i could i feel like this
is just as nice guys are nothing you
know maybe part of it but I think it's
more that people are are disenfranchised
with the whole idea of what they can do
once they're there I mean everyone has
their whatever the particular that
they're gonna be embarrassed by but
people have those a lot of times like
ever get caught so then I miss a word
about that they're more I think he's
talked about good politicians are good
represented representives of our country
they're gonna think I can do anything
anymore yeah i mean i think the scandal
threshold always changes i mean i
remember in the eighties thinking god
are we ever gonna is is having smoked
pot once can always keep you out of
higher office and now nobody cares you
know it's a prereq the practical yeah
and so I think that as time goes on
there there's a level of outrage that
then diminishes I think really what
if you wanna talk about why politics
sucks right now is because politicians
are owned by their corporate backers
because running for office is so
expensive the only people who can do it
are the ones who are in the pocket of
some oil company or some other you know
interest who's going to basically boss
around what they do and safer however
long they're in office and so we're
going to get stuck with more and more
shitty legislation that is pro corporate
and aunty the interests of the American
public well said and you know what if
you're in a really shitty marriage moved
to my Turner's district and then
hopefully this thing happens and then
instead of getting divorced you'll just
but marriage doesn't exist anymore sorry